سؤال محير تطرحه على نفسك عندما تشتري
هاتفا جديدا ماذا سافعل بهاتفي القديم
واذا اشتريت هادفا جديدا فتاكد انه سيصبح
قديما مقارنه بتحديث نفس الهاتف العمل
المقبل هذه الهواتف وغيرها من الاجهزه
الالكترونيه الضحيه منافسه كبيره بين كبر
العلامات التجاريه التي تنفق المليارات
لانتاج موديلات وتكنولوجيا جديده تدفع ما
قبلها الى مكان بالنفايات اطنان والنفايات
الالكترونيه هذه تقدر بنحوي 50 مليون طن
متري سنويا قيمتها اكثر من 60 مليار دولار
فيما تزداد بمعدل سنوي قدره مليون طن خلال
عام
في مصر هناك تجربه ناجحه في هذا المجال
رصدتها سمر رشاد جاءتنا بتقرير التاليه
الكمبيوتر التليفون المحمول وغير ذلك من
الاجهزه الالكترونيه التي لم نعد نستخدمها
بشكل خطوره بالغه على البيئه وعلى صحه
الانسان اذا ما تم التخلص منها بشكل
عشوائي من هنا تاتي اهميه فكره اعاده
التدوير الالكترونيه بشكل صحيح
[موسيقى]
مع طرح اجهزه حديثه كل يوم تزداد رغبتنا
في التخلص من القديم حتى وصل حجم النفايات
الالكترونيه في مصر الى نحو 90,000 طن من
سنويا
الرسمي بتروح في الاخر في التربه ترجع لنا
في الاخر في الاكل في الشرب في المياه
في حياتنا ودي بتاثر بعد كده على الصحه
تسبب سرطان او امراض دم او امراض ثانيه
وزمالك
[موسيقى]
ايه تدوير انت بنعمل قيمه للمخلف اللي في
المنزل في البيت عند المواطن عادي احنا
جعلنا في مقابل
للمخلف ده انت مجرد بتصوره بتحطه على
التطبيق بيطلع لك اقرب مكان تضربه فيه او
تسلم فيه المكلف بتاعك ده بسهوله انا
هاقول لحضرتك الاول يعني ايه مخالفه
الكترونيه زي الموبايل زي الكمبيوتر اي
حاجه
خطوره
هي هذه الشرائح الالكترونيه وما بها من
رصاص ومواد اخرى تمثل خطوره على البيئه
الذهب طبعا الذهب والفضه بيتباع بسهوله
قوي يا كابلات هنا بنطلع النحاس منها
بطريقه امنه
البورده بقى
بتتفك بتروح المرحله اللي هي هناك ديت
بتتكسر
[موسيقى]
التخلص من البيانات الخاصه على هذه
الاجهزه وهو يعتبر اكثر ما يقلقوا صاحبه
الجهاز
لا يتم اعاده تدوير اي هاردسك ومن المتوقع
ان يزداد حجم النفايات الالكترونيه مع
التطور السريع في مجال التكنولوجيا ما
يتطلب زياده الوعي بكيفيه التخلص منها بل
والاستفاده منها ايضا سمر بشكل صباح
العربيه من القاهره
المزيد ينضم الينا الدكتور محمد ابو عمر
الاكاديمي وخبيره التكنولوجيا المعلومات
دكتور اسعد صباحك اهلا بك النفايات
الالكترونيه توصف بالخطر الصامت مع
تحذيرات من ارتفاعا من 50 مليون طن الى 75
مليون طن بحلول 20 30 يعني بما يفوق وزن
سور الصين العظيم اولا ما هي انفايات
الالكترونيه
هي عباره عن النفايات الناتجه عن اتلاف اي
جهاز يعمل بالكهرباء او بالبطاريه و يتحول
هذا الجهاز فيما بعد الى نفايه الكترونيه
الالكترونيه الى قسمين القسم الاول
النفايات الالكترونيه البيضاء
الالكترونيه
البيضاء هي عباره عن النفايات الالكترونيه
الناتجه عن الاجهزه الالكترونيه الاساسيه
الغسالات
الكهربائيه وما الى ذلك اما النفايات
الالكترونيه
الناتجه عن الاجهزه التي تعمل بالهاي
تكنولوجيا لا سيما الاجهزه المحموله
الموبايل الاجهزه اللوحيه التابلت الايه
باد اللاب توب الكمبيوتر وماشابه
الاهم تفضل طيب دكتور محمد يعني اليوم في
المقابل دكتور محمد في المقابل يجري
الحديث عن عيوب لعمليه التدوير تتضمن
تكلفه عاليه ربما مخلفات صحيه اثار ستنجم
عن اعاده عمليه تدوير النفايات
الالكترونيه تضر بالبيئه هذه المره وايضا
مجال لانتشار الامراض هل هذه العيوب محقه
في محلها
اشكرك يا نادين السؤال مهم وفي موقعي هنا
لابد ان اشير الى ان الاجهزه او النفايات
الالكترونيه لها جزئين جود نيوز اند باد
نيوز يعني اشي السيء القاتم الاسود
انها تحتوي على مواد عاليه السميه هايلي
توكسك سبتان لاسيما الفسفور
الزئبق الرصاص الكاتميوم والبروم هذه
عناصر عاليه السميه بالمقابل الجد نيوز
والاخبار الجيده هي ان هذه النفايات
الالكترونيه تحتوي على معادن ثمينه جدا لا
سيما الحديد النحاس الالمنيوم القصدير
الذهب الفضه والمعدن النادر المهم جدا وهو
معدم هنا اريد ان اقول لك ان اليوم اعاده
التدوير السليمه وهو الاسلام
للاجهزه الالكترونيه هو عباره عن اتلافات
من بنسبه 100% كيف ذلك الان وضح لك
الاتلاف اليوم يتم في استراتيجيه منظمه
تتم بثلاث خطوات رئيسه الخطوه الاولى
استخراج المواد السامه من النفايات
الالكترونيه
ومعالجتها لتفادي خطرها وتاثيرها على
البيئه البشر والكائنات الحيه والمناخ
ايضا ثانيا اعاده تدوير ريستايكنج لما تم
من مواد لاسيما الحديد النحاس الفضه
وتحويلها الى مواد خام تستخدم في عمليه
التصنيع وايضا في الصناعات التحويليه
المهم ان عمليه الفصل لهذه المواد اثناء
التدوير تكون بطرق يعنيكيه ومغناطيسيه
وليس بطرق كيميائيه يمكن ان ينتج عنها
ملوثه اخرى للبيئه الاهم من ذلك كله ان 70
في المئه كما اثبت المهندسون الصناعيون ان
70% من المواد الخام الناتجه عن النفايات
الكترونيه يمكن تدويرها المعلومه الاخرى
التي اشار لها المهندسون الكيميائيون وهي
تقول ان كل نفايه الكترونيه معدل تحتوي
على 60 عنصر من عناصر الجدول الدوري اذا
هناك فعلا فرصه لاستثمار هذه النفايات
الالكترونيه وتحويلها الى مواد خام تستخدم
في عمليه التصنيع وايضا في الصناعات في
التحويل
هل في موقع جغرافي معين لاعاده تدوير
النفايات الالكترونيه
هنا انا من خلال صباح العربيه اريد ان
اوجه مناسبه الى كافه الحكومات وفي كافه
الدول الى الاسراء في ايجاد منظمات
ومؤسسات تقوم باستقبال النفايات
الالكترونيه من كتاب المواطنين مقابل
محفزات ربما الماليه او تخطيط الضرائب ومن
ثم تقوم الدول بجمع هذه النفايات وعمليه
اعاده تدويرها واتلافها بالطريقه السليمه
التي ذكرتها السابقه شكرا
في صناعه البطاريات السيارات الهجينه
الهايبرك هذا ايضا
ههه وهذا الصحيح وهذا المعدن ايضا يستخدم
في صناعه الزجاج الثقيل او ما يعرف بالزد
ابلان الذي يستخدم في صناعه النظارات
الطبيه الدقيقه وفي صناعه العدسات
الكاميرات الدقيقه نظرا لان معامل انكساره
مرتفع ايضا يستخدم فيه الالياف البصريه
الفايبر اوبتيكس ل همم ميزته فين في في
النقل العالي والمرتفع والسريع للاشعه ما
تحت الحمراء الاي ار اذا النفايات
الالكترونيه فعلا يمكن ان تكون كنزا
اقتصاديا كبيرا ولكن اذا لم يتم التدويرها
واكتاف بشكل صحيح يمكن ان تتحول الى حرب
شرسه تهاجم المناخ البيئه البشر والانسان
انا اريد ان اقول لك انا منظمه الصحه
العالميه دبليو اتش او في اخر التقاريرها
اشاره الى ان النفايات الالكترونيه اذا لم
تعالج ولم تتلف بشكل سليم وصحيح قد تؤدي
الى او باء كثيره وامراض لا سيما سرطانات
الجيش مهاجمه
مع دكتور جلد شكرا جزيلا لك من طولكرم
الدكتور محمد ابو عمر اكاديمي وخبير في
تكنولوجيا المعلومات شكرا لك